so we're friends again Oh Hilary Duff we
just can't imagine the Disney Channel
without you you made our childhood so
much better and always taught us a moral
lesson or two we're super happy that
Lizzie McGuire is making a comeback and
we can't wait to watch it on Disney Plus
been very hard to even contain my
excitement but we have to ask is your
sister Hayley jealous that you're
working with Disney again because last
time we checked they wanted you not her
the Disney Channel knows talent when
they see it which is why they groom
young actors for stardom every single
day but sometimes they reject actors
they shouldn't have watched until the
end to find out why Neil Patrick Harris
was rejected by Disney and which role he
auditioned for Ariel winter before Ariel
winter was cast as Alex Dunphy in the
hit TV series Modern Family
what is act more like an adult even mean
she had her sights set on the Disney
Channel Ariel was set to play Sunny's
little sister on sunny with the chance
but the script was revised and Ariel's
role was cut Ariel and Demi lavato would
have made hilarious on-screen siblings
but it just didn't pan out luckily
Ariel's contract was terminated allowing
her to audition for Modern Family Ariel
missed out on being a Disney Channel
star but she did land a few voice acting
gigs in 2013 Ariel began voicing Sofia
on Sofia the first Taylor Lautner Taylor
Lautner started acting when he was just
a kid he appeared on the Bernie Mac show
and Cheaper by the Dozen - and even
starred in The Adventures of Sharkboy
and Lavagirl come with us but Taylor was
also interested in dancing and singing
which led him to audition for the role
of Shane and Disney's Camp Rock in the
end the Disney Channel chose to cast the
Jonas Brothers instead and Taylor went
on to play Jacob Black in the Twilight
movies I'm here to warn you so we guess
what they say is true when one door
closes another opens
Taylor Momsen little Cindy Lou stole our
hearts in How the Grinch Stole Christmas
and we have Taylor Momsen to thank for
that
no one should
but before she became Gossip Girl Jenny
Humphrey in 2007 she was caught with her
hand in the Disney jar believe it or not
the Taylor auditions for the role of
Hannah Montana but the part ultimately
went to Miley Cyrus at first being
rejected by the Disney Channel was a
total bummer but as time went on Taylor
realized that the rejection had been a
blessing in disguise
joe-joe back in 2004 dojo inspired teens
everywhere with her breakthrough song
leave and she would go on to become a
well-known pop star and occasional
actress oh my god is your husband
believe it or not but the Disney Channel
had their eye on dodo for quite a while
she was their first pick to play Hannah
Montana however the star breed lies at
the Disney Channel mint business and
they wanted to lock her in a lengthy
contract so endowed Oh showed hesitation
the part went to Miley Cyrus like that
makes a difference do you guys think
that Jojo did the right thing or would
she have had a stronger career if she'd
become a Disney Channel star Naya Rivera
Naya Rivera is a triple threat which is
why she believed herself to be an ideal
candidate for the Disney Channel but it
turns out now I just wasn't who they
were looking for he appeared in a single
episode of even Stephens only to be cast
aside right after but Naya is a fighter
so she pushed through she auditioned for
the lead role in Cheetah Girls and the
role of Gabriella and High School
Musical but never got a callback
luckily Nia's talents didn't go to waste
because she ended up playing the role of
Santana Lopez on Glee smoking hot
Matthew Underwood once upon a time
Matthew Underwood played the role of
Logan Reese on Nickelodeon's zoey 101
I'm thinking about becoming a male model
but deep down Matthew really wants to be
part of the Disney Channel he even
auditioned for the role of Troy Bolton
and got the part
sorry Zac Efron unfortunately for
Matthew Disney had to reject him when
they found out that his Nickelodeon
contract forbade him from taking on the
role tio hum tio Homme was all set to
play the oldest child of Cory and
Topanga in Girl Meets World he broke the
news to his fans and couldn't wait to
start filming within disney chose to
drop the actor in a twist of fate as it
turns out the Matthews family didn't
need an older brother anymore Portillo
rejection is never easy
John Cena although it might be hard to
believe
the big buff John Cena once tried to
become a Disney Channel star however he
took a very backward approach John
auditioned to be Ron stoppable voice
actor in Kim Possible
sink Kim are we gonna make that work
from different continent but he lost the
role to will Friedle who played Eric
Matthews on Boy Meets World
luckily rejection never stopped John
from making it big Kassandra Scerbo
before becoming Vanessa on ABC's Grand
Hotel Cassandra was set on snagging the
role of Hannah Montana she was asked to
audition when the script was in its
final stages Disney Channel producers
were tied between choosing the lead who
could play a seventh grader or one who
resembled a high school student in the
end they chose to go with a younger
actor sincerely Hannah Montana and
Cassandra wasn't welcomed into the
family Neil Patrick Harris just like
John Cena Neil was interested in voicing
Ron stoppable from the hit cartoon Kim
Possible I guess this is it yeah but in
the end the network rejected his
application and sided with will Friedle
instead we're not mad about it though
because Neil went on to do great things
which of these actors would you have
liked to t join the Disney Channel
family sound off in the comments and
that's a wrap subscribe to the things
and give this video a big thumbs up
thanks for watching we'll see you next
time
[Music]